remember that iconic moment when caitlyn
jenner sang tick-tock by kesha on the
mass singer
don't stop my
it speakers a good experience while
kesha finally caught a glimpse of the
performance that aired in march
and she shared her reaction on yeah you
guessed it
tic toc
but then her excitement seems to fade as
she buries her head into her sequin and
feather ensemble
tick-tock on the clock but the party
don't stop
kesha also shares that although she
lives for cover and lives for the outfit
she concluded the caption by writing i
have to go and in her defense no cover
will ever match up to the original pop
anthem
now the party don't start till
[Music]
and interestingly enough caitlyn didn't
really think she nailed her performance
either
it was a big challenge the former
olympian who was revealed to be the
phoenix mask before being eliminated in
the show's first round
told et and march why she was happy to
exit so quickly
that job is tough yeah i mean i
literally work for months
it's a tough show to do it's out of my
element
you know i was known for running fast
and jumping over things and throwing
things you know
but it was a big challenge i was happy
that
i was the first to go i wouldn't like to
go on one more
just because my next song was the
temptations oh
which one were you i know you wanna
leave me
and i was ready to go with that one yeah
hey so i felt pretty good if i could
have gone one more show
because tick tock was kind of a tough
song to do it was a good experience
i like getting out of your element and
taking risks
and even though caitlyn's journey on the
mass singer has come to an end
there's still plenty more to celebrate
on the 20th and final season of keeping
up with the kardashians
i just feel like it's now time not only
did caitlyn confirm she'll appear during
the series final season but she also
reflected on the 10 plus years she spent
being a part of it
we went through a lot together i think i
had probably some of the best
conversations with my kids
on camera you know things happen and as
a parent
you're going oh i better talk to the kid
about that
and you just don't do it as quickly
you know you can't it's uncomfortable
but with the show you have to talk to
them about it like
right now it really brought the family
much closer
i couldn't be more proud they've all
been very successful they've all worked
very hard
great work ethic and they're really good
people so that's the most important
[Music]
thing
you